a new covid vaccine could be available
in the united states by the end of this
month
johnson johnson has asked the fda to
authorize its covert vaccine for
emergency use
now this one only requires a single dose
and does not need to be stored in ultra
cold temperatures the company says that
about a month after taking the shot it
was 100 percent effective
against hospitalization and deaths in
the trials if the fda
approves the vaccine the company says it
could ship
100 million doses in the next few months
our lead national correspondent david
begno is in west virginia at the state's
covet emergency command center david
this news about the johnson johnson
vaccine comes as new
variants of the virus continue to spread
anthony they do and the problem with
that is every time a
virus spreads it has the potential to
mutate and become potentially dangerous
now mutations are common and oftentimes
they're harmless but the more it happens
the more likely it is that it's going to
be a dangerous strain
there are three strains here in the
united states that experts are
particularly worried about
because they're more contagious and this
morning we're going to start with an
alabama woman who lost her husband
because of one of these new strains
ashley jackson says she met her husband
al fanzier
on a blind date was it meant to be from
the beginning let me say it was for me i
was kind of skeptical but
the two were married for nearly eight
years they have two young daughters
but their life together was cut short on
tuesday when alfonsia died
with covet 19. were you able to be there
with him
when he passed away through a window
it was like i was so far away but i was
close but i was so far away
even though the nurse you know held his
hand and stuff it just still didn't feel
the same for me i would rather did that
he had had flu-like symptoms but he
tested negative for covid
he then got short of breath he went to
the emergency room doctors said his
heart was failing
and then a few days later they tested
him again i got the call from the health
department
saying hey your husband has the first
person alabama with the uk strand
that strain was first detected in the
united kingdom
thanks to a national coordinated effort
to sequence samples of the virus
to look for mutations in this case the
strain had become
more contagious and potentially more
lethal identifying a dangerous variant
early enough
is crucial because it could help stop
the spread
while uk scientists recently sequenced
more than twelve thousand coveted
samples in a single week
here in the united states we're only
doing about five thousand a week
it's highly likely that there are
variants that we are not picking up
that is jennifer diane bard she's the
director of a lab at children's hospital
in los angeles
she sequences samples from all over la
county
now she knows what variants are
spreading there but she says labs like
hers aren't getting or they aren't
sharing data
at a national level if we see something
here and let's say it's only one or two
cases
we may not recognize the
importance or severity of it unless
there are also
other states other cities that are
seeing the same thing
mrs jackson says alabama hadn't seen
that variant first detected in the u.k
until they found it in three people
including her husband
did you get the sense that he was scared
yes extremely extremely
he was like i didn't get a chance to
walk my girls down to al
or teach him how to drive he'll have the
opportunity to do those things
you may be wondering did alfonsia have
pre-existing conditions ashley said none
that they knew of he wore his mask he
went from home to work home to work
didn't really have much interaction with
people in the last several months
gail alfonzia died in his mid-thirties
and stories like that david that are so
hard number one to be afraid when you're
dying and number two to be alone and not
be
close to loved ones at the time it's
very tough thank you very much